>> Laura: TIME FOR OUR SEEN AND
UNSEEN SEGMENT.
WE EXPOSE WHAT IS GOING ON
BEHIND THE BIG CULTURAL STORIES
OF THE DAY.
ROSEANNE MAY BE GETTING LESS
POLITICAL AND IS REBOOTED MURPHY
BROWN ABOUT TO TAKE ON FOX NEWS.
WE TURN TO RAYMOND ARROYO?
>> THEY SAID ROSEANNE IS BEING
TO BACK AWAY FROM POLITICS AND
FOCUS ON THE FAMILY THIS SEASON.
TODAY ROSEANNE TWEETED OUT.
THE PRESS MISREPRESENTED WHAT
THE ABC PRESIDENT SAID.
SHE WILL KEEP ON THIS TRAIN WITH
A BALANCE BETWEEN POLITICS AND
FAMILY.
IT'S THE STORY OF THE FAMILY
THAT KEEPS THE FAMILY WATCHING.
>> Laura: TO KEEP BREATHING YOU
HAVE TO HAVE POLITICS BECAUSE
IT'S FUNNY.
MURPHY BROWN.
LET'S WATCH.
>> YOU COULD NOT TELL THE
EVENING NEWS FROM AN EPISODE OF
ENTERTAINMENT TONIGHT.
THE PROBLEM WAS I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO WITH MYSELF.
AND THEN, WE HAD AN ELECTION.
>> Laura: I THOUGHT THAT WAS
BETTY WHITE.
OH MY GOSH!
>> SHE MOVED INTO THE TAPIOCA
SET.
>> Laura: HE LOOKS GREAT.
>> WELL, HER VOICE IS VERY
HUSKY.
SHE'LL BE A HOST LIKE MORNING
JOE.
OPPOSITE HER SON WHO IS ON A FOX
AND FRIENDS TYPE SHOW.
>> Laura: THEN THERE IS A LONG
CAREER FOR ME.
>> THE CBS CHIEF SAID WE WON'T
GET ROSEANNE STYLE RATINGS.
I THINK HE IS RIGHT.
>> Laura: IT WON'T LAST A SEASON
>> Laura: IT WON'T LAST A SEAS N
SEASON.
YOU ARE NOT A BIG FAN OF REBOOT?
>> I AM NOT.
BUT THIS IS ON youTUBE RED AND
IT'S THIS.
>> I HEARD YOU BEAT UP
TEENAGERS.
>> I DIDN'T BEAT UP TEENAGERS.
I KICKED THE [BLEEP] OUT OF
PEOPLE WHO DESERVED IT.
>> THIS IS THE KAWARTHA --
KARATE KID REBOOT.
51 MILLION PEOPLE ARE WATCHING
THIS.
THE BIGGEST STREAMING SHOW IN
ALL OF TELEVISION.
HUGE AUDIENCES.
WHY IS THIS WORK SOMETHING
>> Laura: THE '80s ARE MAKING A
BIG COMEBACK.
>> IT'S NOSTALGIA FOR PEOPLE OUR
AGE.
>> Laura: GREAT HAIR BANDS AND
REAGAN FOR 8 YEARS.
WAS ASOME!
-- IT WAS AWESOME.
>> THEY ARE KILLING THE
COMPETITION AND JUST RENEWED.
>> Laura: MY FAVORITE PART WAS
SWEEP THE KNEE, NOT THE LEGS.
THEN THE BEST ONE WAS WHEN HE
FIRST LEARNED KARATE AND LOOKS
DOWN AT THE GROUND.
EYES!
>> THAT'S WHAT YOU DO ON THE
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" SHOW?
>> Laura: YES, IF THEY DON'T
LOOK AT US.
AND ONE OF THE GREATEST WRITERS,
A BOOK AWARD WINNER.
>> THE INTELLECTUALS IN NEW
YORK, THEY THOUGHT I MUST BE
LIKE THEM WHEN IT CAME TO
POLITICS.
I WENT INTO A ROOM FULL OF
JOURNALISTS OR WRITERS IN
GENERAL, PEOPLE WOULD LOOK AT ME
AS IF I JUST RAISED MY HAND AND
SAID BY THE WAY, I FORGOT TO
TELL YOU, I AM A CHILD MOLESTER.
>> Laura: HE WAS SO GREAT.
>> THE WORD RIGHT STUFF,
LIMITING LIBERALS, GOOD OLD BOY.
ALL OF THOSE TERMS CAME FROM
TOM.
A GREAT NOVELIST.
>> Laura: ONE OF THE BEST
INTERVIEWS I DID ON RADIO WAS
WITH TOM?
>> UNTIL I WAS ON THE SHOW NOW.
>> Laura: EXACTLY.
>> ARE YOU GETTING READY FOR THE
ROYAL WEDDING?
>> Laura: YES.
>> I AM PREPARING TOO.
ARE YOU READY?
I DON'T CARE WHO TAKES HER DOWN
THE AISLE.